What's going on you guys? Man, I got my
friends Giant DLC here and we got an
amazing video to share with you guys
that we're going to be talking over.
Man, you guys excited to get into this?
>> Let's get it.
>> Yes.
>> Let's see. Man, we we got some I mean
some amazing saki level daha going on
here. And uh we're going to we're going
to let you guys judge and see what you
guys think about this. Watch this, guys.
And
>> I was going to ask you what version of
the Quran.
>> We don't have versions of the Quran. So,
I'm like, where do you get this
information from? Um because they they
are
>> Hold on a second. You don't have
versions of the Quran? Huh? What? Has he
not seen a giant DLC live stream? What
do you mean we don't have versions of
the Quran? What? What are you talking
about, man?
>> Has he not heard of Muhammad Hijab and
Yaser Khadi?
>> And it's very clear to you and to every
single very advanced student and
specialist that the standard narrative
has holes in it. That's what I'm going
to say.
>> I don't think he's seen that in
>> I don't think he's seen that. Let's see
what it maybe he's going to clear it up
here. Hold on.
>> Every group that calls itelves Muslims
believed their own Quran
>> that basically come to that and accepted
one.
>> Can you show me two versions? I'll be
happy to see.
>> He just said he'll be happy to see if we
can show him two versions. John giant
DLC.
>> Two versions. That's all he wants.
That's all he want.
>> We can show him 20.
>> We can show him to All right. Well,
look, I'm going to let y'all cook, man,
because he said he will be happy if we
could just show him two versions of the
Quran. So, let's see if if if we if we
got that, man. What we got here? What we
got here?
>> We got the different names of the
virgins.
>> Yes.
>> Stop it. That got to be
>> So, okay, we got one version of the
Quran and we have another version of the
Quran and we'll show exactly what's
going on here. So, on the left we have
Huffs. On the right we have Albazi.
Okay,
>> those aren't two versions, are they?
>> Yeah, these are two different versions.
Look at this. Two completely different
readings that Muslims consider to both
be divine. both be divine. So they say
this one is 100% the Quran and this is
100% the Quran. So these are two
different versions of the Quran.
>> Wow.
>> Which is strange because one of them is
81, the number of the verse, and the
other one is 80. They even have
different numbers
>> in the it's just made to appear that
it's a little different. That's all.
>> So let's read let's read the verse. So
they said, "Oh Lot, indeed we are
messengers of your Lord. They will never
reach you. So set out with your family
during a portion of the night and let
not any among you look back except your
wife. Indeed, she will be struck by that
which strikes them. Okay. So let's focus
on this part here. Except your wife.
>> Yeah.
>> And let's go back to the Arabic and see
what exactly it says here.
>> Okay. So on the on the left side you got
huffs,
right?
>> Focus on the right hear that. That's
what that's what you guys got to hear.
>> It has a which means the a vowel on the
wife, right?
>> Yeah.
>> On the left we got the other version.
>> There's a on the sound except your wife
on that on on that side. So what's the
difference?
>> Now what's the difference? What's
happening in the grammar there is the
first reading huffs says so set out with
your family during a portion of the
night except your wife. So he's being
commanded to set up with his family
during a portion of the night except his
wife. So his wife is not coming with him
>> to leave the wife behind.
>> The other reading says, "So set up with
your family during a portion of the
night and let not any among you look
back except your wife."
>> So she look back.
>> So she's coming with them, but she's
going to look back. So everyone else is
going to be there, but she's the only
one that's going to look back. So is she
coming or not? Is she committed to come
or not? And if she comes in that version
of the bezi,
>> she will look back.
>> She will look back.
>> Yeah. Uh for for any Muslim, for any
person who takes Western scholarship,
they hear what western scholars have to
say. Here's Marin Van Putin who's well
known for his contributions to Quranic
studies, Islamic studies. He comments on
this verse and he says that the majority
reading says, "So travel with your
family except your wife." And then Abu
Omar and Ib Kir which Albazi is one of
Ib Kathir's readers reads it as and no
one of you shall turn around except your
wife again. So is she commanded to come
with him or not? It depends which
version of the Quran you are reading.
>> Wow. So you mean to tell me you got two
different commands here and this isn't
in the English. This isn't in the
English. This is in the Arabic. Hoffs
vers versus Albazi. Depending on which
reading, which Quran you're reading,
which version of the Quran you're
reading, you get a different command.
You get a different order in regards to
Lot's wife.
>> Exactly.
>> Correct. And you can't have both because
the angel would have only commanded them
once and they would have only come out
once.
>> So a Muslim might say, "Okay, that's
just us or that's just Mutin." Okay,
what what do our scholars have to say?
Good question. So let's go to Ibika. We
have Ibad on the screen right here and
let's see what he says in English. So I
cir says here except your wife. The
majority said that this is an exemption
from the affirmation which means what?
Then travel with your family. It's
implied meaning being except your wife.
Okay. So the majority says travel with
your family except your wife. Meaning
your wife is not coming with you. She's
not coming to come with you. However,
others among the readers in Grimarian
said, "And let not any of you look back
except your wife." In other words, she's
coming with you, but she's going to be
looking back.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's I cir
Putin, a western scholar, modern western
scholar, and then we have a classical
Islamic scholar.
>> Now, wow.
>> Let's look at if we have any more Muslim
scholars, maybe in the more modern
period. Let's see. Let's go to a modern
authoritative scholar from the 20th
century by the name of Shehiti.
Let's see what he says.
>> He says, and I'll read it in the Arabic
here in the highlighted section. He's
saying there is a contradiction in the
verse.
>> Wait, wait. A Muslim scholar
>> is admitting that there's a
contradiction.
>> Yeah.
>> No way.
>> Oh, he's saying what we're saying. So,
it's not just what Marian Putin said.
It's not just what we said. It's not
just what I said. But now you have a
modern 20th century Muslim scholar who's
very authoritative saying that there is
a contradiction
>> and that's the word here. That's the
word for contradiction in the Arabic.
>> So even they see it that's incredible.
>> Of course they do.
>> That's crazy.
>> So when you got these Muslim dies coming
out here like Muslim lantern, Shikman,
these guys coming out, you know, telling
their Muslim fans that there's only one
reading of the Quran. There's only one
Quran. All the Muslims believe in one
Quran. It's a flatout lie. Huh?
>> Big lie. No matter who says it, Muslim
light bulb, Muslim that, Muslim this, it
is a complete lie. The Dawa script, all
it is is a script. It's full of lies.
And this is how you debunk that with one
simple verse. Wow.
>> We have more verses.
>> Oh, yeah. We got we got we got ton more
verses. And so this was just one
example, ladies and gentlemen, of how
easy it is to demonstrate the Muslims
myth that this entire narrative that
there's only one Quran that all Muslims
memorize, that all Muslims believe in,
this entire narrative has holes in